hello everyone sorry about that now
after seeing that nice game between 11
Arlen Fabiano Caruana you requested for
me to show this game Kurwenal versus
Mahmoud Europe it's also from the st.
Louis rapid event and it's definitely
quite a game very interesting sacrificed
by Mahmoud Arif and then you know all
all hell breaks loose
so it's Fabiano Khurana who is currently
the world chess championship challenger
in regarding rating he is number two in
the world only second to Magnus Carlsen
and Sharma Arif who you've just seen win
at the 2018 bill chess festival not only
that he wanted to two full points ahead
of world champion Magnus Carlsen
so definitely an interesting matchup you
know the Battle of twenty-eight hundreds
always always a pleasure watching a game
like this
so before we check it out we do have a
nice photo challenge to gain points in
this photo challenge you have to be able
to name all three gentlemen in this
photo so there we have it
I don't think it will be too difficult I
was taken in 1983 in the in the in the
candidates so best of luck to everyone
pretty sure you'll be able to recognize
all of them now let's check out the dis
game so like we said Corona has the
white pieces in he opens with E 4 we
have e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and Bishop
to b5 Dora Lopez a6 rush up to 1/4 or
more fees defense Knight to f6
we have castles and here mama drf
captures on e4 d 4 we have b5 Bishop to
b3 and then out d5 pawn captures an e5
we have Bishop to e6 and now Knight bTW
- so all standard stuff 95 attacking the
bishop c c3 now offering black to grab
the bishop pair but the knight on c5 is
a it's quite a nice piece
so Bobby doesn't the material doesn't
capture the Bishop Bishop to d7
we have Bishop to c2 and the now comes
d4 a very nice idea by mama DRF Knight
to b3 and now d3 rush up to be 1 and now
Knight captures an b3 a capture some b3
and the now Bishop to a5
mom Java now guards his past d3 porn so
it's a move 14 and mama D already has a
nice pass pawn on d3 and if if he will
be able to defend it then this will
definitely prove to be a very nice asset
later in the game
b4 we have castles and now comes h3
Queen to d7 preparing to bring the rook
into the game but also maybe later it
could be used as a nice attacking
resource Bishop to f4 and now comes the
rook F to D 8g for pushing the bishop
back G Bishop to g6 and the now Bishop
back to g3 h5 we have Knight to e2 and
the now comes H captures on g4 Fabi
recaptures H captures on g4 and this is
the first really cool moment of the game
here of course the standard move is a
five as a six is your backwards pawn you
know you do want to get rid of it either
open up the a file or if white doesn't
react to this even push a four and then
okay he does have another point on b2
but still seems like the best idea here
but my meter has a different plan
he plays Knight capture some before so a
piece sacrifice C capture some before
it's the best move
and now Bishop capture some before so
given up a piece for two points and but
now after he plays c5 and c4 he will
create a beautiful pond chain here on
the Queen side that will you know go all
the way across the board
Bishop - 8 - we have c5 and now comes c6
a very important move that before mama
dog was able to push c4 and block
completely fabiana's light square bishop
he manages to get this e six move in and
it's the best move definitely the engine
agrees that now the Queen cannot capture
of course you don't want to allow the
pawn captures on f7 f captures on e6
displayed and now this will be a target
for the remainder of the game ninth to
f3 and the now c4 so okay
my meteor is now up three points for the
piece but also if you look at the
Fabiano's light square bishop
not really doing all that much it's it's
not even as if mama Dora was down on a
piece Knight to e5 would an attack on
the Queen and the bishop Queen yet
guarding the brush up on g6 and King to
g2 karana is preparing to bring the rook
over to the open h-file rook to d5
attacking the knight on e5 and now f3 we
have night the rook to b8 doubling rooks
on the D file rook to h1 and now okay
it's a very nice rook a very active on
each one what your mama D are really
takes the initiative by playing Bishop
to d6 now the knight on e5 is attacked
twice so what do you do here
Fabiano defensive with Queen - E - and
now you have two options you can either
capture and after white recaptures only
then push d2 which is also very nice but
yah goes immediately for d2 so Queen to
e3 and now comes the bishop to see - the
threat of course now is pawn to d1 bring
your queen into the game and after rook
captures then in grab the rook of course
you don't want to allow that so you have
to block it with the rook Bishop
captures rook captures and the now comes
better captures on e5 Bishop captures on
e5 and here again this Bishop isn't all
that great here na - as you can see here
Medea of has two rooks and Corona has a
rook and two bishops so two bishops for
a rook is usually perfectly fine even
better of course but here not so much
because the pawns are really strong and
it will be very hard to get rid of the
past d2 pawn and here mama tariff
manages to play the only move that
allows karana to seize the initiative
here he could simply just continue with
Queen c6 queen e7 going for g5 if the
Queen never moves maybe even h4
but here he plays Queen to d2 d3 and
rook to d3 allows this bishop to get
back into the game with tempo so first
Queen to e4 and now it doesn't matter
even if you move the rook still Bishop
to be one will come with tempo as Queen
to h7 will be a threat so rook 8 the d5
and now comes the bishop to be one there
no getting out of this now you cannot
move the rook if you move the rook for
example Ruby three you're getting
checkmated Queen eight seven check King
moves and now Queen captures and g7 this
will be checkmate
so after Bishop to be one Queen to f7
was played and the now comes virtual
capture Sundy three rook captures on d3
and now Queen to eight check after that
route to this remove mama dr again makes
a mistake with this Queen to have seven
move he shouldn't have left the back
rank because now if you move the King
then it's over immediately after rook to
h1 check King moves now you can check
here after King moves you can check here
after King characters you can check with
a discovered check after King moves you
can see move play Queen a four and this
will be checkmate so here you have to
decide what to do of course you cannot
go with the King you have to block with
the Queen Queen to f8 but now Fabi
simply captures the Queen we have
captures captures and now although
Mammadov still has a lot of points for
the piece three extra points for the
piece here Fabiana place better up the
c3 he attacks mama DRS passed pawn twice
and also the bishop is honor darks were
completely cutting off any play my media
might have had on the Queen set because
none of the points can go to a dark
square so in to e7 nothing to do here
for black anymore
king of two we have g6 rook captures and
e2 rook captures and now Bishop captures
and again if mommy Turk could somehow
get rid of these pawns then perhaps he
could hope for a draw here but this
Bishop is simply too strong and the
Queen side it will not be possible
King d6 we have Bishop to b4 check King
moves now King brings Fabi brings the
King into the game King e5 Bishop d2
King d5 f 4 now King to c5 it doesn't
matter even if you bush see five white
will simply push f5 captures captures
and afteri for King f4 and there is no
no nothing to do here the pawn and King
are creating a wall here even if you try
to go back but should be 4 check will
again completely cut off the king so
after f4 came to c5 was played
we have Kingi for before now came to e5
we
a-five King captures on e6 and now King
2b for f5 simply creating a passed pawn
on the kingside G captors on f5g
captures on f5 and now King to d3 Bishop
to F for a 4 and now we had f6 b3 f7 and
the now comes c3 be kept frozen c3 was
played and it was in this position I
move 56 that world number 3
Charlie my media resigned the game why
did he resign well whatever he plays for
example if he continues a3 then he's
simply not fast enough
Bobby will bring the Queen into the game
and after a to a queen to a3 stops any
pawn advances king c2 defending the b3
porn but now comes Quincy 1 check the
bishop is guarding c1 and here black
would simply get checkmated even even
after bring your queen into the game and
if instead of a3 you push b2 immediately
then unfortunately for my review get f8
Queen B be one Queen and now this
unfortunate check Queen to a5 check the
king he has to move and then the Queen
is captured so after we captures on c3
mamita resigned the game and a very nice
victory for Fabiana Caruana if by any
chance you missed my previous video that
wonderful game also from the st. Louis a
rapid tournament between our Union and
Caruana I will put a link to it in the
description but also feel free to check
it out and there I also have shown the
the standings after after day 1 but in
case you fail to you know see that video
here they are car 1 is still in first
place with 6 points because you get two
points for a victory then maxime
beaugeois graphic Oricon mama D are in
fourth then we fountain anakata Nakamura
11 Iranian linear Dominguez Alexander
Grisha and Wesley so in the last place
with 1 point only one draw yeah that's
the game Fabiano Carano vs. chakram on
media of rule number number 2 versus
world number 3 I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I will make one of them are
known vs.
Fabiano game so feel free to check that
out as well I would like to thank Jamie
commas
Daniel Dre leach and Sean wilcoxon for a
contribution to my channel think a lot I
really appreciate it and yeah I'll see
you guys soon